Traduttore: Sofia Ramundo
Revisore: Silvia Fornasiero
Buonasera a tutti,
mi chiamo Salvatore Aranzulla,
ho 27 anni e oggi vi racconterò
i passi che mi hanno portato
a diventare un divulgatore informatico
e un imprenditore digitale.
La mia storia nasce
in un piccolissimo paese della Sicilia,
si chiama Mirabella Imbaccari,
è un paese di 1.000 abitanti,
un po' come le persone che sono
qui oggi in questo teatro.
Un paese minuscolo
nel cuore della Sicilia.
Lì, all'età di dieci anni,
riuscii a convincere i miei genitori
a comprarmi il primo computer.
Mio cugino Giuseppe
mi prendeva sempre in giro,
perché lui aveva un computer.
Mi diceva: "Guarda, io ho
un computer, tu non lo avrai mai!
I tuoi genitori non te lo
compreranno mai",
fino a che ebbi un'idea:
portare i miei genitori
in un negozio d'informatica
in un paesino vicino,
aggrappare il primo computer che vidi,
incominciare
a piangere, a strillare,
e costrinsi i miei genitori
a comprarmi un computer.
Questo fu l'inizio della mia storia.
Tornammo a casa
e a casa avevamo questo oggetto;
né io né i miei genitori
sapevamo cosa farne,
sapevamo come utilizzarlo,
era un oggetto che stava lì,
che mi incuriosiva,
era un qualcosa di nuovo.
Io nel frattempo avevo
dieci anni, andavo a scuola,
quindi tornavo a casa,
facevo i miei compiti
e la sera premevo il bottone,
accendevo il computer
e incominciavo a smanettare.
Incominciavo a vedere
come utilizzarlo,
a come risolvere i problemi
che incontravo giorno dopo giorno.
Nel frattempo anche i miei amici
incominciarono ad avere
i loro primi computer
e cominciarono i "sequestri di persona"
di Salvatore Aranzulla.
Avevano un problema?
Venivano a prendermi
a casa con la forza,
mi portavano come un pacco
a casa loro chiedendomi:
"Salvo, sistemami questo problema".
E mi resi conto subito di un qualcosa:
più persone presentavano
lo stesso problema,
più amici mi ponevano la stessa domanda.
Da qui l'idea di risolvere il problema
solamente ad un mio amico,
di scrivere la soluzione
all'interno di un documento word,
stamparla e darla agli altri.
Diventai uno spacciatore
di soluzioni manuali
tra i miei amici a scuola.
Distribuivo i compiti in classe,
ero bravo, ma distribuivo anche
le soluzioni per risolvere
i problemi con l'informatica.
Il passo chiave è stato
all'età di dodici anni,
quando creai 'aranzulla.it'.
Aranzulla.it nasceva
come un sito amatoriale,
un sito nel quale pubblicare
quei documenti word
con le soluzioni che davo ai miei amici.
Era gestito in maniera amatoriale.
Immaginate un ragazzino di dodici anni
che ha accesso ad Internet
e che dal piccolissimo paese della Sicilia
pubblica dei contenuti
e questi contenuti li mette su Internet.
Figuratevi che non avevo
la più pallida idea
di chi leggesse questi contenuti.
Fino a quando ebbi un'idea nel 2007:
inserire in pagina un codice
per vedere quante persone
leggevano i miei contenuti.
Rimasi a bocca aperta.
300 mila persone al mese
consultavano il mio sito Internet
per risolvere i loro problemi.
Un qualcosa che mi lasciò esterrefatto:
300 mila italiani consultavano
le istruzioni scritte da me
nel tempo libero.
Nel frattempo stavo
per terminare gli studi,
io studiavo al liceo scientifico
di Piazza Armerina,
un paese accanto al mio in Sicilia,
e dovevo scegliere quale università fare.
La mia ambizione era quella di studiare,
non tanto informatica,
io sono autodidatta sull'informatica,
quanto piuttosto economia;
il mio sogno era entrare in Bocconi.
I miei genitori non potevano
permettersi di pagare l'università,
la mia è una famiglia modesta.
Mia madre fa la casalinga,
mio padre fa l'infermiere,
ed ho tre fratelli,
Giuseppe, Elia e Davide.
Quindi non avrebbero potuto
permettersi la possibilità
di mandarmi a studiare a Milano.
Per caso scoprii
l'esistenza di un servizio:
si chiamava, e si chiama
ancora oggi, Google AdSense.
È un servizio semplicissimo:
avete un sito Internet
e volete monetizzarlo, volete guadagnarci?
Vi iscrivete su Google AdSense,
prendete un codice, lo mettete in pagina
e da quel momento in poi Google,
per conto vostro, vende della pubblicità.
Questa pubblicità è legata
ai contenuti del vostro sito Internet,
se parlate di informatica
troverete pubblicità di informatica,
se parlate di motori probabilmente
troverete della pubblicità sulle auto.
Il primo mese incassai il doppio
dello stipendio di mio padre.
Qualcosa...
I primi soldi che, appunto, arrivarono
li investii totalmente
nella mia istruzione.
Finii di studiare al liceo scientifico,
mi spostai finalmente a vivere a Milano,
era il mio sogno,
dal piccolo paese alla grande città.
Andavo all'università,
andavo in Bocconi,
come i miei amici seguivo
le lezioni, studiavo a casa,
con l'unica differenza
che il weekend e le notti
le passavo a lavorare
al mio sito Internet.
Quindi, tutto il tempo
che riuscivo a ritagliarmi
al di là dello studio
era dedicato al mio sito Internet.
L'anno 2008, quindi 2008-2009,
furono gli anni diciamo
nei quali il mio sito cominciò a diventare
un qualcosa di importante per me.
Era vitale per me che il sito funzionasse
perché senza quello non avrei potuto
permettermi di studiare.
Troppe cose si accavallarono
e purtroppo fui costretto a fermarmi.
Scoprii di avere una malattia,
che si chiamava colite ulcerosa,
fui ricoverato in ospedale
un paio di mesi
e fui costretto a bloccare tutto.
Da una parte avevo la Bocconi
che richiedeva una presenza costante,
dall'altra dovevo cercare di fatturare,
dovevo cercare di mandare avanti
il mio sito Internet, la mia impresa,
tutto si era fermato.
Il mio sito Internet
continuava ad essere letto,
ma non da abbastanza persone
da rendermi sereno.
In ospedale ebbi un'idea, un'intuizione:
perché non trovare quello
che gli italiani cercano sull'informatica
sui motori di ricerca?
Perché devo essere io
ad inventare le tracce
da trattare sul mio sito internet?
Sviluppai un sistema,
che esiste ancora oggi,
e si chiama sistema dei titoli.
È una tecnologia proprietaria
che inventai all'età di 18, 19 anni
ed è un sistema che analizza quello
che voi cercate sui motori di ricerca
e mi consente di vedere
quali sono i problemi
che gli italiani hanno sull'informatica.
In questo modo,
io e i miei collaboratori
riusciamo a dare la risposta
ai vostri problemi.
Qualsiasi problema che voi cercate
sull'informatica sui motori di ricerca,
probabilmente finite su aranzulla.it.
Aranzulla.it oggi è diventato
un'impresa a tutti gli effetti;
ho superato le difficoltà iniziali
che ho avuto nella mia carriera
di imprenditore.
Oggi aranzulla.it è tra i 30 siti
più visitati in Italia.
Se prendete una classifica
trovate Google, trovate Facebook,
trovate YouTube,
trovate una sfilza di siti porno
e poi trovate anche aranzulla.it.
(Applausi)
Soprattutto, un altro dato interessante
è che ogni giorno 500 mila italiani
consultano il mio sito
per trovare una soluzione.
Un numero impressionante.
Ma quello che mi emoziona di più
non sono tanto i numeri,
non sono tanto le cifre, i fatturati oggi,
è quanto piuttosto
l'entusiasmo delle persone
che mi fermano
per strada per ringraziarmi,
che, appunto, hanno risolto
i loro problemi con l'informatica.
Sono anche le lettere, le email
che ricevo dalle persone.
Io ricevo ancora, spesso,
delle lettere da persone anziane.
Ne ho ricevuta una circa un mese fa,
di un signore di 85 anni
che mi ringraziava
perché seguendo una mia guida
era riuscito a installare Skype
sul proprio computer
e quindi a riuscire a vedere i nipotini
che si trovavano
dall'altra parte dell'Italia.
Queste sono grandi soddisfazioni al di là
delle cifre, dei numeri, dei fatturati
che si possono ottenere.
Peraltro lo stesso signore,
in questa lettera,
aveva allegato dieci euro dicendomi:
"Guarda, non smettere,
questo è quello che posso,
l'importante è che non smetti
perché altrimenti non so come sistemare
il mio computer in caso di problemi".
(Applausi)
Ho cercato oggi un po'
di riassumere la mia storia,
un po' per tappe,
le tappe più importanti,
soprattutto per dare
uno stimolo ai miei coetanei.
Io vedo moltissime persone della mia età
che sono senza lavoro,
che non sanno cosa fare.
Internet fornisce
una grandissima opportunità
per trasformare quelle che sono
le proprie passioni in un lavoro;
quindi fornisce delle opportunità
anche a quelle persone che magari
sono in cerca di un lavoro
e che magari possono decidere
di crearlo, appunto, da zero,
come ho fatto un po' io partendo
da un piccolo paese della Sicilia
ed essendo diventato quello che sono oggi.
Grazie per l'attenzione.
(Applausi)